Christiane Lemke Expertin für
internationale Beziehungen Marino
Comparis bei uns Redakteurin im
hauptstadtbüro das Magazins der Spiegel
Felix Lee schreibt für China table das
ist ein ja ein digitalmedium anders
ausgedrückt eine Informationsplattform
im Internet für die für diese schreiben
und Erik Kirschbaum ist bei uns
US-amerikanischer Journalist sie
schreiben unter anderem für die Los
Angeles Times bevor wir hier im Studio
loslegen eine Schalter in die
europäische Hauptstadt nach Brüssel zu
unserem
ard-kollegen Michael Grütz Korrespondent
dort vor Ort willkommen bei uns Michael
Götz heute war ja das Treffen der
nato-botschafter in Brüssel mit dem
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens Stoltenberg es
ging natürlich um die gestrigen Ereignis
in Polen den Raketeneinschlag ist sich
denn jetzt die NATO einigermaßen sicher
dass die Rakete nicht von Russland
abgefeuert worden ist also weder von
russischen Truppen noch von russischem
Territorium aus
ich denke schon also ich zitiere ihn
vielleicht mal aus der Rede von Jens
Stoltenberg heute Mittag auf der
Pressekonferenz er sagte wir haben kein
weiß darauf dass dies eine Ereignis
eines absichtlichen Angriffs war und wir
haben keinen Hinweis darauf dass
Russland Offensive Militäraktionen gegen
die NATO vorbereitet und das hat er
ungefähr noch fünf oder sechs Mal im
Laufe dieser Stunde Pressekonferenz
wiederholt mein Eindruck ist dass sich
das auch schon gestern Abend relativ
zeitig abgezeichnet hat dann gab es
viele Telefonate zwischen Bali und
Brüssel und Polen zwischen Joe Biden und
dem Generalsekretär der NATO und da hat
man vor allem das Wording offensichtlich
abgesprochen heute morgen dann kam Polen
mit der Meldung die ich gerade so auch
vom Generalsekretär zitiert habe er kam
dann auch damit äh gegen Mittag also ich
glaube man ist da relativ sicher auch
wenn das letzte Wort und das letzte
Ergebnis noch nicht gesprochen ist
gleichwohl hat sehr entstanden wäre ich
darauf hingewiesen trotzdem ist sie
Verantwortung bei Moskau denn mos nur
für den Krieg gegen die Ukraine und ohne
einen solchen Krieg hätte es auch diesen
Vorfall nicht gegeben scheint ja
trotzdem bei einigen westlichen Staaten
so ein bisschen faxhausen gegeben zu
haben wegen dieses Ereignisses jetzt
geht es ja um die Ostflanke der NATO die
Ehe gestärkt werden soll wird diese
Stärkung der Ostflanke jetzt noch weiter
forciert vor allem in zeitlich
beschleunigt
bei wem hat es dieses Fracksausen wohl
nicht gegeben gestern Abend als diese
erste Meldung kam ich glaube da waren
sehr viele Leute nervös was jetzt
angezeigt ist machte Stoltenberg
insofern klar als dass die fundamentalen
Annahmen der NATO sich nicht wesentlich
geändert haben schon seit Beginn des
Krieges wird konstant aufgebaut an der
Ostflanke und dies wird man auch
weiterhin tun und immer wieder aufs Neue
überprüfen es gab eine Reihe von
Angeboten wie man die Flugabwehr noch
einmal stärken kann wie man die
überwachungsstärken kann und vor allem
geht es aber darum dass die Prioritäten
in der Ukraine gestärkt werden hieß es
ähm dass ich einzelne naturmitglieder
zusammensetzen und koordinieren wie sie
auch dort die Flugabwehr noch weiter
stärken können soweit Michael Götz aus
Brüssel vom NATO Hauptquartier
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Information
gerne ja Frau combarki
hat die NATO aus ihrer Sicht auf diesen
Raketen Einschlag gestern besonnen
reagiert hat sie einen Stresstest
bestanden ja die NATO ist seit fast neun
Monaten die der Krieg bereits andauert
peinlichste rum bemüht nicht Partei
nicht aktive Kriegspartei in diesem
Konflikt zu werden und das hat sie auch
heute einmal mehr bewiesen in dem
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens doldenberg
sehr deutlich wir haben es gerade gehört
sehr klar darum bemüht gewesen ist die
Gemüter zu beruhigen Ruhe reinzubringen
wir haben die haben ja die Backen gehabt
über die Aktivierung von Artikel 5 der
nato-karte der das Bündnis falls genau
also das wäre eine Jahr muss man so
sagen eine krasse Eskalation dieses
Konflikt gewesen die Debatte lief in den
sozialen Netzwerken und da hatten wir
heute versucht die Luft rauszunehmen und
ich würde sagen es ist ihm mit diesen
sehr klaren Worten mit dieser
Besonderheiten
zurückgehalten hat mit mit Wertungen und
auch zur Besonderheit aufgerufen hat
Frau Lemke Michael kürzer dass er auch
gerade gesagt zumindest mittelbar ist
Russland ja der Verursacher dieses
Einschlags ist dieses Ereignis auch so
eine Art Blaupausen für eine mögliche
Eskalation des Krieges gegen die Ukraine
ja man darf nicht vergessen das ist eine
brandgefährliche Situation also die
Raketen reichen ja bis nach Lemberg im
Osten im Westen der Ukraine Osten von
Polen liegt nähern nah dran also es ist
auch nicht auszuschließen dass solche
Unfälle sage ich jetzt mal so passieren
auch die baltischen Staaten sind höchst
besorgt also es ist eine sehr
angespannte Lage eben auch für die NATO
Mitglieder und insofern ist es ganz
wichtig dass man übt wie man in so einem
Krisenfall reagiert nicht und nicht
überreagiert sondern auch versucht eben
sich zu koordinieren ganz wichtig also
dass man sich abspricht und das eben
auch keine der betroffen verschiedenen
Ländern die so unmittelbar an der
Ukraine angrenzen in alleinggängen
arbeiten sondern dass man das wirklich
auch abspricht in der nato-zentrale
diese mögliche ölläufe gestern war ja
offenbar Bestandteil eines regelrechten
Bomber in dem morgens auf die Ukraine
Putin hat ja gestern Raketen und
Marschflugkörper auf die Ukraine
regelrecht niederprassen lassen um die
Infrastruktur zu zerstören
warum hat er das gemacht ist das so eine
Rache für den Verlust von Sonne oder und
vielleicht auch für die
Abschlusserklärung auf Bali
ja wir können nur spekulieren ich meine
das Timing war schon interessant Lavra
war gerade in der Luft glaube ich und
dann ist es alles passiert aber keine
Ahnung aber ich glaube das war die ganze
Ereignis hier war ein bisschen ein in
einer Probe von NATO und es ist gut dass
es alles ruhig geblieben ist ich fand es
auch ganz positiv das muss dann könnte
ganz schnell sagen das war nicht von von
uns ich glaube wenn die hätten
vielleicht etwas anderes gesagt oder gar
nichts gesagt und dann beiden hat
relativ schnell gesagt von der von der
Laufbahn können wir sehen das war
wahrscheinlich nicht von Russland ich
war das sehr positiv dass wir wussten
alles relativ schnell das ist wirklich
nicht so besonders war und das passt in
den ganzen Politik von beiden von Anfang
an beiden probiert zu dscalieren wie es
geht der er will nicht dass der Krieg
eskaliert äh probiert ähm Ukraine is the
healthin aber ganz klar Ukraine keine
Waffen zu geben die offensiv in Russland
genutzt werden kann das wahrscheinlich
zur gleichen Zeit Donald Trump in Malaga
gesehen wie man als amerikanischer
Präsident tatsächlich in der Welt
Geschichte agieren soll erli den
Chinesen wird ja Putin immer
unheimlicher auf Bali wurde ja auch mit
Unterstützung Pekings eine Verurteilung
des Ukraine Krieges beschlossen sind
denn die Scheidungspapiere zwischen
China und Russland schon eingereicht
naja so weit würde ich noch nicht gehen
es ist natürlich ein positives Zeichen
dass China überhaupt dieses die
kommuniki zustimmt auch wenn er dieser
Zusatz ist einige Staaten
also es gibt dann Hintertürchen also
China kann immer raus reden
jetzt nicht uneingeschränkt dem
zugestimmt aber zwei Dinge sind ja
bemerkenswert erstens das ist in dem
kommuniki von Krieg Gerede ist China
selbst hat ja das wurde Ding von Putin
immer übernommen gehabt und ihre seine
Diplomaten seine Politiker und seine
Medien verpflichtet von einer
sonderoperation zu sprechen und das
jetzt erstmals auch von dem Krieg
gesprochen wird dann auch damit auch in
China das ist schon ein Zeichen dass
Ping also der chinesische Staatschef
sich zunehmend von Putin distanziert
wobei das alles noch sehr in typisch
Schritt Erfolg also es ist keine
komplette Abkehr von Putin das ist noch
nicht zu ernten wir haben ja im Titel im
Untertitel Putin im Abseits Fragezeichen
ist er denn trotzdem auf internationale
Bühne jetzt ziemlich ziemlich nicht ganz
isoliert aber ziemlich isoliert kann man
das sagen
würde ich sagen ist nicht isoliert aber
es wird doch einsamer um ihn herum
allein schon sein Fehlen auf Bali hat ja
deutlich gemacht dass Russlands Platz in
der internationalen Gemeinschaft in
Zweifel steht und auch die vorzeitige
Abreise seines Außenministers labroff
hat daran nichts geändert also es
bröckelt der Zuspruch für Russland auch
weil China aber auch Indien merken dass
dieser Krieg und das ist das was diese
beiden Staaten glaube ich am meisten
umtreibt ihren vornehmlich ökonomischen
wirtschaftlichen Interessen massiv zu
widerläuft ich würde gerne besprechen
war in gx7 in Bayern im Sommer war das
nicht ganz so einig in dir und so und
Indonesien die Wahlen ein bisschen mehr
proteind und jetzt sieht man dass es
kommt eine große
Isolierung von von Russland die diesen
wirklich alleine hier und aber auch
diese diese Treffen von Shorts und pink
vor ein paar Wochen wo der dann gegen
diese Tom Krieg auch gesprochen hat das
fand ich ganz äh Atomwaffen das fand ich
habe ich nicht damit gerechnet deswegen
das verurteilen würde das sind so kleine
Schritte aber eine gute positive
Richtung dass Russland zunehmen isoliert
ich glaube diese
nuklear Putins nuklear Drohung ist für
China fast ein Ausweg sich aus diesem
Irrtum von diesem Irrtum zu
verabschieden china hatte ja erst den
Krieg mehr oder weniger oder zumindest
Putin mehr oder weniger unterstützt und
gemerkt dass das ein Irrweg ist also das
China hat auch sich völlig
hat völlig unterschätzt oder überschätzt
wie schwach Putin oder seine die
russische Armee tatsächlich ist und ich
glaube fast dass diese nukleardrungen
von Putin jetzt ein Ausweg ist für China
sich dann auch von positiv
damit zu rechnen dass jetzt auf dem G20
Gipfel ja ehemalige oder Verbündete
Russlands oder Freunde oder jedenfalls
oder auch Unterstützer jedenfalls keine
großen Gegner so auf Distanz gehen also
ich finde ganz wichtig dass man hier
dann sieht das solche Foren wie geht's
20 die ja doch in Verruf geraten waren
die sieben G20 alles große Konferenzen
kommt nichts bei raus dass das so nicht
stimmt sondern dass diese Foren
außerordentlich wichtig sind um alle an
einen Tisch zu bringen und auch um
Beschlüsse zu fassen die dann doch
vielleicht umgesetzt werden können und
da würde ich auch sagen der indonesische
Staatspräsident verdient natürlich auch
Lob der das Ganze organisiert hat und im
Vorfeld offenbar dafür gesagt hat dass
er sowohl den Herrn lavrov sehr
freundschaftlich begrüßt hat so sahen
die Bilder aus aber er blieb hart in der
Sache und er hat glaube ich im Vorfeld
auch dafür gesorgt dass diese Gespräche
überhaupt zustande gekommen sind so dass
eben auch Russland es sehr schwer hat
überhaupt seinen Anspruch
sofern Russland überhaupt nach Ansprüche
formulieren kann in der internationalen
Gemeinschaft dafür ein Forum
herzustellen weil inzwischen die Länder
gesehen haben welche völkerrechtlichen
Probleme mit diesem Krieg verbunden sind
ich würde doch gerne ein wenig Wasser in
den Wein gießen ja das war zweifelsohne
geht 20 auf Bali war in der Tat ein
Lebenszeichen einer einer vitalen
Diplomatie das ist ja nicht wenig in
Zeiten von Krieg und Krise zu mal nach
drei Jahren Pandemie aber
bedrucktes Papier was eine solche
Abschlusserklärung nun einmal ist ist
das eine das andere ist ja die reale
Politik und wir sehen China Indien sind
Russlands beste Kunden was Öl anbelangt
kein Staat der Welt kauft derzeit mehr
russisches Öl zum Discountpreis dass die
beiden bekommen als diese beiden ja also
ich will mal sehen was dieser Erklärung
diese eben erwähnt haben tatsächlich
folgt ja aber die Preise sind natürlich
was Indien zahlt für das russische Öl
ist lächerlich das ist für Russland kein
großes Geschäft und ich denke im Moment
mag das funktionieren aber andere Länder
dazu gehört auch Indien aber eben auch
Indonesien andere große Länder im
Pazifik sehen auch wie wichtig das ist
Gespräche mit westlichen Ländern zu
führen über Technologien Klima Politik
ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema in
asiatischen pazifischen Raum das soll
man nicht unterschätzen und ich denke
von daher sind auch die bilateralen
Gespräche die vorher und am Rande und
natürlich auch hinterher stattfinden
außerordentlich wichtig und das machen
die Amerikaner uns vor da können wir
vielleicht auch eine Scheibe noch mal
abschneiden dass man mit Indien und mit
China sehr intensive Gespräche führen
muss aber eben auf einer bilateralen
Basis wenn sich Putin nur noch auf
Nicaragua Nordkorea als treue was allen
verlassen kann was bedeutet das
eigentlich für ihn dann also wenn er
tatsächlich dieses Gefühl hat er es
isoliert er kann auch sein Interessen
mit Hilfe von anderen großen Mächten
nicht mehr durchsetzen wird er dann
Einlenken zu Verhandlungen oder oder
erst recht eskalieren weil er sich das
hat man ja schon öfters als Psychogramm
über ihn veröffentlicht sich in die Ecke
gedrängt fühlt sich dann so fragen also
wenn ich mit dem Boden nein Wasser aber
man kann nur sehen dass der der verliert
dann kriegt der Krieg läuft schlecht für
ihn und seine Freunde werden sich von
ihm ab und ich kann mir vorstellen dass
Puten wenn er klug ist oder nachdenkt
der hat einen Plan dass ein Plan B dass
irgendwas muss verhandelt werden am Ende
und es geht ihnen es geht wirklich nicht
gut verboten muss man schon sagen der
hat ganz Vorstellung gehabt ganz andere
Ideen hat gedacht die Deutschen würden
nicht so einig sein mit den anderen
Partnern hier die haben gesagt ihr könnt
euch weiterhin sein Gas Gas hier
verkaufen er hat wirklich falsch
kalkuliert und es läuft nicht gut wenn
wir diesen Gedanken zwar weiter spinnt
und auch die Gefahr hin dass ich weiter
eine
spekulative Frage stelle wenn man
Russland wenn man jetzt russland sieht
und auf den offensichtlichen
militärischen wie diplomatischen
Misserfolg von Putin muss er da auch im
eigenen Land auf der Hut sein na ja klar
putin ist darum bemüht Russland als eine
geopolitische Großmacht darzustellen vom
Westen gefürchtet und vom Rest der Welt
respektiert also diese diese Erklärung
von Bali macht ihm das eigentlich schwer
wobei wir wissen ähm unterwegs starker
Kontrolle des Krimi die russischen
Medien letztlich stehen also da hat er
direkt Durchgriff was aber die letzten
Tage gezeigt haben diese diese
unverfrorene verbrecherische
Dreistigkeit mit der
Russland einen regelrechten Raketenhagel
über die Ukraine hat niedergehen lassen
während die G20 getagt haben zeigt dass
er nach den Niederlage im Süden der
Ukraine nach der Rückeroberung von
Carson nicht zur Deeskalation nicht
zufriedensgesprächen wie manch einer
hofft bereit zu sein scheint sondern
weiter am eskalationsregler dreht indem
er die ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung
einem ja terroristischen
terroristischen Leid unterzieht Alicia
ist voll schon angesprochen was das
Verhältnis China Russland angeht dass
sich in diesen langsam auf Distanz gehen
wie weit ist dieser Prozess eigentlich
gedient man könnte ja sagen je nachdem
was jetzt passiert im Ukraine Konflikt
und was ich Pudding noch alles einlässt
das eigentlich ein Putin hi und den
Chinesen so richtig die Tour vermasselt
denn die haben ja auch Interessen vor
allem ökonomische Interessen sie können
ja eigentlich oder wollen Ungarn in
einen Konflikt hineingezogen werden der
erstens mal nicht bei ihnen stattfindet
den sie sowieso nicht beeinflussen
können
und den sie wahrscheinlich schon immer
mit einer gewissen Skepsis betrachtet
haben naja gut der Krieg ist ja noch
leider lange nicht vorbei also insofern
ist man kann vielleicht beim G20 von
einem Teilerfolg sprechen aber
entschieden ist ja noch lange gar nicht
und und auch bei China also die
Strategie ist ja ursprünglich im Grunde
versuchen Nutzen aus diesem Konflikt zu
ziehen also sprich Russland
gewissermaße in die Abhängigkeit von
China zu drängen und aber auch dem
Westen eines auszuwischen weil darum
geht es jetzt letztendlich auch um die
große geopolitische Auseinandersetzung
die USA und der Westen versus China also
die USA haben ja nicht umsonst China als
den Hauptgegner erklärt und nicht so
sehr Russland also und das geht jetzt ja
natürlich weiter und da halte ich auch
die weltweite geopolitische schlagen
weiterhin für sehr sehr
Angestellten die europäische
hinzufügen Aspekt die Perspektive da
noch zu Ende bringen ich habe das ja
auch gerade in dem Gespräch mit Michael
Grütz angesprochen
wird die NATO denn jetzt gezwungen sein
diese sogenannte Ostflanke schneller und
vor allem militärisch viel stärker
auszustatten dass das was jetzt da auch
die 100 Milliarden die dann die Hand
genommen werden die Erhöhung der
Verteidigungsausgaben am Inlandsprodukt
betrachtet wird das jetzt sehr viel
schneller und auch voluminöser gehen
also einmal muss man feststellen die
NATO ist ja eindeutig gestärkt worden
also genau das Gegenteil von dem was
Russland wollte die NATO ist gestärkt
ist sehr viel schlagkräftiger hat sie
sich aufgestellt und das liegt einmal
natürlich daran dass die USA eine
führende Rolle übernommen haben aber
eben auch daran dass die Länder die nah
an der Ukraine liegen ähm innerhalb der
NATO auch eine Lobby bilden um das mal
so zu sagen um diese Ostflanke zu
stärken Polen ist im übrigen dabei
selber die größte europäische Armee
aufzubauen
und was wir ja auch sehen ist das Länder
wie Finnland und Schweden in die
natodrängen Finanz-
zehraum natürlich von der NATO praktisch
ja beherrscht wird wenn man so will und
das sozusagen die Gradwanderung ist
jetzt das haben wir vorhin schon
angesprochen natürlich will die Nato
nicht Kriegspartei werden auf keinen
Fall und sie möchte auch nicht in die
Situation kommen durch einen
Zwischenfall durch einen Unfall eine
unklare Situation sind ja dann eben auch
sehr starke
Bedrohungsszenarien die beide Seiten
vielleicht sehen
in den Krieg hineingezogen zu werden das
will sie vermeiden deswegen rechne ich
nicht damit das z.B Raketen
Abwehrsysteme in Litauen oder lettland
hat das glaube ich auch vorgeschlagen
oder in Polen direkt stationiert werden
sondern man stärkt die Ukraine man
bildet die Kräfte aus in der Ukraine
sendet Waffen und
Raketenabwehrsysteme und so weiter aber
ich denke das Polen mit der Aufrüstung
jetzt doch einer der wichtigsten Partner
in der NATO sein wird also Auto gestärkt
geopolitisch natürlich vor allen Dingen
dass die Bundeswehr was die militärische
Ausschüsse angeht gestärkt wäre oder
stärkt worden ist in den letzten Monaten
kann man noch nicht behaupten oder noch
nicht behaupten diese diese neue
Konzentration der
außen-sicherheitspolitik gerade in
Europa auf die Ostflanke auf den
Bündnisfall ja wenn er den Eintritt weg
von Auslandseinsätzen
überfordert dass die Bundeswehr bzw da
muss er Olaf Scholz da müssen ja alle
gerade in den eigenen Parteien noch eine
Menge Überzeugungsarbeit leisten dass
das nicht nur eine
Neuorientierung der Strategie ist
sondern wahrscheinlich auch noch eine
Menge Geld mehr kostet wenn er darüber
wenigstens Einigkeit herrschen würde
wir haben in dieser Woche darüber
berichtet dass die Bundeswehr
tatsächlich ein Strategiewechsel anteilt
also weniger Auslandseinsätze wie man
das jetzt zwei jahrzehntelang in
vornehmlich Afghanistan beobachten
konnte hin zur Landes- und Bündnis vor
allem NATO Bündnis Verteidigung aber
darüber ist man sich innerhalb der
Bundesregierung zum einen noch nicht so
ganz klar also das
Verteidigungsministerium drängt in
Richtung bündnisverteidigung das
auswendige Amt vornehmlich sagt nein
lasst uns mal unsere internationalen
Verpflichtungen im Rest der Welt nicht
vernachlässigen ich glaube es wird auf
ein beherztes sowohl als auch
hinauslaufen aber wie sie sagen dass
erfordert sehr viel mehr Mittel als in
den 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen für
die Bundeswehr enthalten sind also da
sieht man jetzt schon in den
Berechnungen des Ministeriums in den
Berechnungen der Bundesregierung da
kommt man hinten und vorne nicht hin
wenn man in politisch wird ja nicht
einfach werden da die SPD einen ziemlich
kritischen Flügel auch gegenüber einer
Aufstockung der Militärausgaben auch bei
den Grünen gibt es da viele die er
gerade diese 100 Milliarden auch gerne
noch in ökologische Projekte umgeleitet
hätten das war ja erst der Anfang der
Diskussion und auch der Konfrontation
auch innerhalb der Ampeln der Streit
wird auf jeden Fall weitergehen ich
denke wir das zunächst die Einigkeit
groß darüber war auch angesichts des
Schreckens dieses dieses Krieges der
alle in dieser vehements sicherlich
überrascht und überfordert hat aber
Verteidigungsausgaben in Zeiten von
Rezessionen sind sicherlich ein ziemlich
umstrittenes Feld und werden es auch
bleiben auf der Welt gucken bisschen
weiter nach Osten wandern von Europa Weg
der Kirschbaum
Joe Biden und heating konnten drei
Stunden nicht voneinander lassen
ziemlich langes Gespräch war auch eine
einigermaßen höfliche Begrüßung am
Anfang so was wir optisch alles
mitbekommen haben ist dieses Gespräch
auch was da besprochen worden ist auch
in diesem ganzen Rahmen in dieser
Atmosphäre eigentlich ein gutes Zeichen
das ist gerade zwischen diesen beiden
Staaten vielleicht auch sich etwas die
eskaliert
hinten auf jeden Fall das war viel
länger als geplant und ähm die kennen
sich schon also bei Vizepräsident war
das fand ich das erste Mal und die haben
viel miteinander gesprochen und ähnliche
Zielen aber es sind interessantes china
hat andere Dinge bekannt gegeben als die
USA nach dem Treffen ja und äh china
will nicht so sehr als Alliierten der
USA da auftauchen von diese Kriege gegen
Russland und das ist natürlich ein gutes
macron und Scholz auch da waren damit
ähm ein bisschen bestimmen Europa werfen
könnte aber nee ist natürlich
wenn die drei Stunden miteinander reden
und und ähnliche Ziele vor allem zu
verhindern dass es war eine Tom Queen
kommt in Ukrainers will keine und ich
finde USA war wirklich sehr besonnen die
ganze Zeit in Europa hat man ab und zu
Angst das Puten das erste meint und die
amerikanische Geheimdienst haben immer
ganz genau beobachtet was passiert
passiert irgendwas
dass die Amerikaner das richtig gesehen
haben das war nur heiße Luft von Puten
und so ist es ein Glück
gemacht hat als stünde wer ein
atomkriegt nicht weit weg und
sie haben wahrscheinlich die beiden
beiden und hier sind pink wenig über
oder weniger über die Ukraine als
vielmehr über den direkten Konflikt
gesprochen den sie in Ostasien haben
Stichwort Taiwan da haben sie sich ja in
deutlicher Klarheit sind sich da
begegnet was ich da gelesen habe da ließ
also die Klarheit zwischen beiden nichts
zu wünschen übrig man hat nicht um den
heißen Brei rum geredet sondern klar
gesagt und festgestellt wir haben zwei
tief rote Linien ähm die dürfen nicht
überschritten werden China darf nicht
Taiwan äh okkupieren und falls das
passiert gehen die Chinesen davon aus
dass ich die USA raushalten ist in
dieser Konflikt selbst wenn man so klar
anspricht und diese Offenheit ist ja
eigentlich erfreulich ist dieser
Konflikt langfristig wirklich zu
vermeiden nein das glaube ich nicht weil
sie den Ping hat sich ganz klar zum Ziel
gesetzt weil waren ein zu verleiden von
Wiedervereinigung will ich immer nicht
sprechen weil es Teil waren die Teil der
Volksrepublik
aber da kommen wir ja schon auf das
Wording also
beide haben beide Seiten haben darauf
geeinigt den Status vorzugelassen aber
der Status Quo wird völlig
unterschiedlich verstanden und da war
hat ja China schon in den letzten Jahren
dazu beigetragen da eine massive
Verschiebung auch das wordings
vorzunehmen also lange Zeit war Status
Quo halt dass es ein China gibt
offiziell aber zwei unterschiedliche
Systeme und das wurde so lange Zeit auch
so akzeptiert und das hat Peking
zunehmend unterhielding eben nicht mehr
akzeptiert und das bezeichnet er jetzt
als Status Quo und insofern ist der
Konflikt beileibe überhaupt nicht
beigelegt man hatte vielleicht ein
bisschen Spannung rausgenommen und man
kann jetzt davon ausgehen dass beide
Seiten jetzt nicht das Interesse haben
das in den nächsten Zeit noch mehr
zuzuspitzen aber im Kern ist der
Konflikt überhaupt nicht beigelegt ich
im Gegenteil ich glaube der wird sich
auch noch mal zu spitzen zu mal die
Amerikaner oder auch die Nachbarstaaten
in von China also die Länder die
Anrainer starten Sie Chinesisch mehr ja
höchst alarmiert sind Japan südkore über
alle Staaten sind ja höchst alarmiert
Australien und wissen wollen auch
versuchen China was entgegenzusetzen
zumal China ja auch massiv weiter
aufrüstet in einer Beziehung hat Joe
Biden die Politik von Donald Trump
weitergeführt nämlich China einzudämmen
hat das ja eigentlich fast noch
verstärkt kann man den sagen dass im
Moment die ganzen Kalamitäten die
Bedrohungen für die Weltwirtschaft China
ja auch stark davon betroffen ist als
ein Land das viele Handel betreibt dass
das die beiden von den Dummheiten
militärischer Konflikte im südlichen
mehr abhält ist das eher im Moment so
nach dem Motto wir machen jetzt so einen
brauchen wir die friedenspreise mal
gucken wann sie wieder ausgeht aber im
Moment ist es eigentlich keine Option
der militärisch aneinander zu geraten
vielleicht fürs Erste was dieser Gipfel
im Bali gezeigt hat ist das ist da
einige Gesprächsbereitschaft gibt ich
glaube das Timing war auch insofern
günstig als beide sowohl Joe Biden als
auch zu den Ping in ihrer Machtposition
bestärkt worden sind jetzt in den
vergangenen sagen Ping durch seine
Wiederwahl ja auf Lebenszeit muss man
wohl sagen auf dem Kongress der
Kommunistischen Partei in Peking und Joe
Biden bei den bei den Zwischenwahlen in
den USA vor wenigen Tagen wo die
Demokraten jedoch deutlich besser
abgeschnitten haben als sie selbst
befürchtet haben also zwei Männer zwei
Politiker die sich ihrer Macht
einigermaßen sicher sein können für den
Moment und deswegen auch fürs
innenpolitische Publikum jetzt nicht so
ganz hart dieselbe Rasseln müssen
das hat man da gesehen also der ist
jetzt Raum für Diplomatie aber ich würde
da hin vollkommen zustimmen der der
Großkonflikt der ist noch lange nicht
abgeräumt im Gegenteil der deutet sich
mitmacht an und man hat übrigens auch an
der Reise Route von Kanzler Scholz
gesehen der ja zuvor in Singapur gewesen
ist in Vietnam auch gewesen ist all das
Bemühungen die Abhängigkeit von China zu
verringern zu diversifizieren das ist
das große Schlagwort und heute bin ich
mal kurz Werbung eine Sache leben darf
vom Spiegel berichtet die
china-strategie der Bundesregierung die
Bundesregierung geht gerade mit Macht
rein in den Versuch tatsächlich sich
weniger abhängig zu machen von China
stärker die Menschenrechte in den Fokus
ihrer Wirtschaftspolitik zu rücken und
ja in diesem geopolitischen Konflikt USA
hier China dort nichts zwischen die
Fronten zu geraten wie wie abhängig sind
wir von China wirklich also ich würde
ganz gerne noch mal kurz auf die
amerikanische Strategie gegenüber China
zu sprechen kommen also ich sehe da auch
im Moment unlösbare Position was Taiwan
angeht aber so eine Art Burgfrieden
erstmal nur wenn man sich der
amerikanische Außenpolitik anschaut und
das in den größeren Zusammenhang stellt
ist es glaube ich so dass die Amerikaner
sehr früh erkannt haben dass ihre
Vorherrschaft im Pazifik sehr stark
unter Druck geraten ist durch ein China
dass ich sehr viel stärker nach
außenwendet sowohl wirtschaftlich als
auch militärisch im Südchinesischen Meer
Stichpunkte aufgebaut hat aber eben auch
wirtschaftlich mit den asiatischen
Anrainer Ländern
über über Wirtschaftshilfen Aufbauhilfen
Kredite und so weiter versucht ja genau
das ist genau die Wiederholung der
afrika-strategie und das ist für mich
insofern ein Problem dass ich hier in
Deutschland aber auch in Europa sehe
dass man das nicht erkennt also in
Afrika haben wir gesehen wie China als
Türöffner mit Krediten arbeitet die
Länder abhängig macht und die Länder
selber in Afrika davon eigentlich gar
nicht profitieren von den chinesischen
Investitionen und dann werden
Sicherheitsabkommen geschlossen das
bedeutet chinesische Truppen werden
stationiert oder irgendwie
Sicherheitssysteme ausgetauscht und das
gleiche passiert im asiatischen
pazifischen Raum jetzt haben die USA
sehr viel mehr Verbündete also die
Länder sind schon genannt Japan
Australien Neuseeland
Philippinen das sind alles Verbündete
der USA aber China versucht eben mit
macht auch da weit parteiwan hinaus
Einfluss zu gewinnen wirtschaftlich aber
dann vielleicht auch militärisch und das
ist wirklich eine große Herausforderung
das wird ja bedeuten dass die Chinesen
die USA in der Rolle des Weltpolizisten
gerne ablösen würden amerikanische Sicht
auch so gesehen ja ich weiß nicht ob die
Amerikaner wirklich unbedingt
Karriere natürlich ist Deutschland in
Europa viel zu Abhängigkeit China die
deutschen machen den gleichen Fehler mit
Schienen was sie mit Russland gemacht
haben und vielleicht sehen die das
vielleicht ein bisschen wach geworden
und probieren da die Bremse einzutreten
aber weiß nicht was Volkswagen in
deutsche Autoindustrie in China jetzt
hat aber die die sind total abhängig
davon die machen genau den gleichen
Fehler und diese Fehler ein Fehler was
man vielleicht ein kleines gesehen hatte
Russland hat gesehen dass ihr am Armee
und ihre Waffen sind gar nicht so stark
und die sollten vielleicht ist eine
Lehrer die werden vielleicht überlegen
wer Taiwan äh wenn ich sehen was für ein
Fehler muss dann hier mag und diese
amerikanische nato-standard Waffen sind
wahrscheinlich überlegen und und Schiene
wird Taiwan nicht so einfach übernehmen
diese starke Steins Strategie von Taiwan
ist wichtiger Lehrer die jetzt in dieser
Ukraine Krieg für Europa und und China
zu Fragen der Abhängigkeit also ich
würde den ein bisschen widersprechen
also ich würde nicht sagen dass die
ganze ganz ganz Deutschland oder die
gesamte deutsche Volkswirtschaft
wirklich abhängig von China sind es sind
halt bestimmte Firmen groß Firmen also
wenn man sich anguckt das ein Drittel
der EU-Investitionen im letzten Jahr
Jahren in China von drei Firmen kommen
nämlich von drei Deutschen fünf
Volkswagen BASF und Siemens dann zeigt
sich ja und die bestimmen im Grunde auch
die Politik deswegen es gibt ja auch in
Deutschland überhaupt kein Konsens Jetzt
ist vom Außenministerium vom Grün
geführten Außenministerium die China
Strategie durch euch bekannt geworden
das sind die grünen Positionen ich
glaube da wird es noch viel gerammelt
geben in den nächsten Monaten weil die
SPD das überhaupt nicht so sieht da
wirklich stärker auf Konfrontation mit
China setzen zu wollen weil sie eben
auch die Interessen dieser
Großindustrie der deutschen
Großindustrie im Auge hat und wie gesagt
es sind aber nur einige wenige große
Firmen die bestimmt aber ganz massiv die
China-Politik des Kanzlers aber er hat
ja jetzt äh in Asien eine Marina
kompakia der sie gerade angesprochen
hätte wohl den Asien tatsächlich eine ja
Offensive gestartet der Bundeskanzler
mit dem Besuch in Vietnam und danach in
Singapur das sind ja das sind ja die
Tigerstaaten die da auch wirtschaftlich
sehr stark sind um eben zu diese
diversifizieren also die Abhängigkeit
von China zu vermindern ist das trotzdem
richtig ja kann man machen das ist so
seine denke zu sagen irgendwie wir
diversifizieren wir erweitern den Handel
quasi erweitern unseren
handelsspielraum da aus Südostasien aber
er macht ja überhaupt keine Anstalten da
jetzt zu gucken in welchen Bereichen wir
vielleicht von China auch Abstriche
machen sollen und ich würde persönlich
sagen es gibt bestimmte Bereiche wo ich
Deutschland dann doch auch von Produkten
die man aus China bezieht
pharmakologische Produkte selten Erden
in bestimmten Technologiebereichen dass
da die Abhängigkeit von chinesischen
Produkten zu groß ist und da merke ich
vom Kanzler bisher noch kein großes
Bestellungen Produkte kann man auch
hierherstellen selten können wir hier
schlecht Ausgaben
und so weiter hat man in den letzten
Jahrzehnten komplett ausgelagert und da
gibt es tatsächlich eine Abhängigkeit
von China und das ist natürlich Problem
weil damit macht man sich erpressbar und
ich würde mir vom Kanzler da wünschen da
doch auch mal in den Bereichen genauer
hinzuschauen und das heißt natürlich
auch Abstriche zu machen also nicht nur
zu gucken wie man den Handel erweitern
kann auf andere Länder das kann man
immer machen aber die Frage ist ja ob
man bereit ist auch weniger handeln mit
China zu führen und das sehe ich von der
SPD geführten unserem Kanzleramt bislang
noch wenig Schritte bei den Grünen sieht
das schon anders aus Investitionen in
Deutschland sich sehr viel kritischer
anzuschauen die EU hat ja nicht umsonst
der Hafen in Hamburg liegt mir sehr nahe
ich komme aus der Gegend
und sagt wollen wir das ein
Containerhafen von chinesischen
Investoren übernommen wird weil man
damit natürlich auch sozusagen die Tür
öffnet für für Wissenstransfer nach
China oder auch Einflussnahme bei
wichtigen Entscheidungen und das ist ein
sensibler Bereich genauso die Chip
Industrie alle Informationstechnologien
also da muss man sehr genau hingucken
und da haben die Amerikaner schon früher
kapiert dass man da also ähm genau
aufpassen muss und die Amerikaner Chips
bestimmte Chips nicht mehr in nach China
liefern einfach weil sie auch die
Benutzung in verschiedenen
Überwachungssystemen und so weiter in
China ablehnen ne und Handel ist nicht
einfach
lokal sondern es werden bestimmte
Produkte für bestimmte Bereiche
gehandelt und da kritischer hinzuschauen
glaube ich ist ganz wichtig warum werden
denn die USA den Deutschen in Europäern
dann noch mehr auf die Finger schauen
oder Druck ausüben diese Abhängigkeit
von von China zu vermindern ich glaube
wir tun dass er lange auch Trump hat
gegen hoher gewarnt ja vor ein paar
Jahren nur die deutschen Denken
in Deutschland die Amerikaner wurden
es ist so blauäugig das war wirklich
geost strategisch gemeint gut gemeint
aber zumindest habe ich glaube ich seit
beiden Präsidenten die ähm und er will
Europa in Deutschland als als Alliierten
gegenüber Schiene gewinnen und die
Deutschen und die Amerikaner reden mehr
auf und ich glaube Deutschland ist
spätestens seitdem Ukraine Krieg ähm
wach geworden von der von der Gefahr von
dieser Abhängigkeiten der beiden ist
aber maximal bis Ende 2024 ähm
und danach muss man sich wahrscheinlich
auch hier neu aufstellen was das
Verhältnis zu den USA angeht
das ist Panikmache entschuldigung aber
ich meine das weiß heute keiner das ist
zwei Jahre von jetzt und auch wenn Trump
jetzt tönt er tritt mit der Hand das
könnte ja auch jemand anderes sein auch
von den Demokraten der möglicherweise zu
Europa nicht die Beziehung hat wie schon
beiden aber die USA haben ein sehr
großes Interesse an Bündnispartnern das
ist das eine militäre strategisch und
auch an dem wirtschaftlichen Austausch
Europa ist der wichtigste Handelspartner
für die USA warum sollte man da sagen
wir wollen keine Beziehung mehr nach
Europa ich sehe eher den umgekehrten
Trend und würde die vier Jahre von
Trump diese nationalistisch
isolationistischen Jahre eher als die
Ausnahme der amerikanischen Außenpolitik
einordnen und doch würde ich hier
einwenden dass die deutsche die
europäische Politik sich darauf wirklich
jetzt höchste Zeit einstellen muss auf
auf eigenen Bein zu stehen wir haben es
jetzt in den USA wir haben Donald Trump
hat eben seine Ambition für eine weitere
Kandidatur bekannt gegeben wenn man sich
heute mal die amerikanischen Medien
anschaut ja der die Tragödie in Polen
findet Erwähnung Ukraine findet
Erwähnung und doch ist alles absorbiert
von der Wiederauflage von diesen von
diesen DejaVu einer politischen ja
reality TV Show die Trump da jetzt
einmal mehr abziehen wird also die USA
werden jetzt Steuern auf Wahlen zu sie
werden massiv innenpolitisch ja von sich
selbst absorbiert sein das heißt
natürlich auch für Europa ein Stück weit
übrigens auch mit Blick auf die
Unterstützung der Ukraine mit ähm
Waffenhilfe aber auch mit ökologischer
Sicht überlegt in welchen Situationen
die ja Europa in Deutschland gerade ist
war da die Reise Diplomatie des Kanzlers
in letzter Zeit recht erfolgreich er hat
ja nicht nur nach
Ellmau zum G7 Gipfel Indien Südafrika
und Indonesien eingeladen er war in
Südafrika er war jetzt Indonesien er war
Singapur er war in Vietnam macht das
Sinn dass man da versucht auch eben
diese Blockbildung insofern zu
verhindern dass diese Länder zumindest
sich nicht entweder Russland an den Hals
werfen oder generell eigentlich Anti
europäische Politik betreiben auf jeden
Fall ist das sinnvoll und ich würde mir
nur bei Scholz konkret doch mal ein
bisschen mehr Absprachen mit der EU mit
anderen EU-Ländern wünschen und eben
nicht von diesen deutschen allein gegen
die teilweise von den europäischen
Partnern auch kritisiert werden also
insbesondere die sich China-Reise der
hat durchaus in diesen 11 Stunden bei
dieser stimmt Visite das Beste
herausgeholt er hat auch kritische
Themen wie Menschenrechtsverletzungen in
China und so weiter auch angesprochen
auch die Handelskonflikte die es gibt
aber er hat es leider nicht ausreichend
abgesprochen das war zwei Wochen nach
dem krönungsparteitag von alleine
Herrscher und deswegen meine große Angst
ist tatsächlich deswegen weiß ich nicht
ob das Panik machen ist schon dass die
in zwei Jahren eine Konstellation haben
die wo die USA dann doch wieder viel
viel stärker mit sich selbst beschäftigt
sein werden und China hat ein wahnsinnig
langfristigen strategischen Plan den
China unter chilien pingen eisern
verfolgt und da das ist eine
Herausforderung für alle Demokratien
weil wie ich zugleich auch merke
immerhin hat Deutschland jetzt oder die
Diskussion um eine china-strategie ist
jetzt im Gange aber meine Befürchtung
ist dass das alles viel zu lange dauert
und China da schon längst große Schritte
vollzogen hat militärisch technologisch
und wahrscheinlich
da auch in Kürze dann
viel noch viel
schlagkräftiger sein wird als das jetzt
bereits der Fall sein ich muss zugeben
mit chinesischen Humor kenne ich mich
nicht aus aber ich soll ja auch bei dem
Gespräch mit Emmanuel macron auf Bali
gesagt haben die Europäische Union und
China sollten den Geist der
Unabhängigkeit und Autonomie waren gegen
die USA war das nicht gemeint
hat er dann Fable für Sarkasmus dass die
europäischen aus mit China den Geist der
Unabhängigkeit und Autonomie gemeinsam
waren will das ist schon eine sehr
blumige Ausdrucksweise ist zu der Ping
offenbar offenbar neigt in
Ausdrucksweise die viel Raum für für
Interpretationen zulässt ja interessant
auch dass er das ging über macron
geäußert hat der da jetzt auch nicht mit
allzu großer Schärfe gegenüber
der Schafherde melden ähm
na ja China unterschiedlichen
spaltet also das da gab schon mehrere
Versuche da die 16+1 Gespräche Osteuropa
von quasi Westeuropa zu spalten Europa
von den USA zu spalten also und das
gelingt China auch teilweise ganz gut
weil China einfach eine sehr mächtige
Wirtschaft macht oder
Wirtschaft Staat ist und mit Geld sich
doch vieles erkaufen lässt und leider
sind da die Europäer da auch nicht ganz
in den letzten man kann so immer wieder
diese Äußerung die westlichen
Demokratien die liberalen Demokratien
Design unter Druck von allen Seiten
selbst aus den eigenen Reihen Stichwort
Trump und das Friendly Fire gegen die
Verbündeten
ist es gerade anders ist der
bestmöglicherweise gerade wieder im
Vorteil nachdem Ereignissen die wir aus
den letzten Wochen jetzt da erfahren
haben also wir haben auch Probleme wir
brauchen nur die Europäische Union uns
anzuschauen und Polen Ungarn
innenpolitisch zu anzuschauen großes
Problem
das Vereinigte Königreich ist auch nicht
gerade in einer sehr guten Position
Italien also wir haben durch den
Aufstieg von Rechtspopulisten in Europa
ein großes Problem
trotzdem würde ich sagen dass dieser
Ukraine kriegt dazu geführt hat die
europäischen Länder wenigstens
außenpolitisch zu einem das ist ein
großes Fund das müssen wir auch
weiterentwickeln also ich bin sehr dafür
dass die Europäische Union wie Sie
richtig ehrlich gesagt haben auch
aktiver wird und auch mehr tut
außenpolitisch ein eigenes Profil zu
gewinnen aber mit den USA und ich würde
sagen die Liberalen Ordnung sind nach
wie vor unter Druck das ist überhaupt
nicht
weniger geworden
gut wir müssen es an dieser Stelle
beenden das Thema wird uns aber wie bei
vielen Phoenix runden die Themen immer
noch weiter beschäftigen ich bedanke
mich bei Christiane Lemke bei Marina
kumbalki bei Felix Lee und bei Erik
Kirschbaum Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer morgen in der Phönix Runde
Wettlauf gegen die Zeit was bringt der
Klima Gipfel der ja morgen in Charm el
Sheikh zu Ende gehen soll aktuell sind
weiteres bei Phoenix der Tag mit Stefan
Kohle und da werden wir uns noch mal
genauer mit den Raketen Einschlägen in
Polen Befassen mit möglicherweise neuen
Erkenntnissen bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]
die Anzahl der Tage mit Temperaturen
über 50 Grad auf der Welt hat sich seit
den 1980er Jahren verdoppelt
es ist keine normale Hitze eher wie
Feuer die